[Music]
buzz lightyear mission log stardate 3901
after a full year of being marooned our
first hyper speed test flight is a go
who are you talking uh no one
you were narrating again i was not just
doing the mission log you do know no one
ever listens to that i know that
narrating helps me focus
ready captain light you ready as i'll
ever be commander hawthorne this is
exciting a new adventure i'm gonna grant
you four minutes to be off planet but
then you come right back to us
to infinity and beyond
and you are clear for hyperlaunch
buzz that was utterly terrifying and i
regret having joined you
buzz lightyear to star command come in
star command
why don't they answer
hey
the robots the what
what is happening right now
alicia oh no that's my grandmother but
sucks how long were we gone
62 years seven months and five days
what
i hope you're ready for action because
all we needed was a pilot for what to
destroy the alien ship
i have a plan and i have a team darby
can take any three things and make them
explode
i do this and they shave a little time
off my sentence okay and what about you
well i thought this was gonna be like a
fun boot camp workout thing
but it is not
did i get it pretty close i need that
anyone saying the harpoons
[Music]
right here
the probability of survival with an
inexperienced crew is 38.2
seems a bit low
mission failure imminent in three
grandma always said she believed in you
too
one there was a big swelling too i think
i need a better oh no please record your
last words do not vomit inside the
vehicle you're not vomiting
if you are satisfied with this recording
speak or select one
[Music]
to infinity are you trying to get me to
pull your finger don't fall for it no
not like that sorry it's the thing your
grandma and i used to do yeah